this episode is brought to you by Peak
that's p-i-q-u-e I have had so much tea
in my life I've been to China I've lived
in China and Japan I've done tea tours I
drink a lot of tea and 10 years
plus a physical experimentation and
tracking has shown me many things Chief
among them that gut health is critical
to just about everything and you'll see
where tea is going to tie into this it
affects immune function Weight
Management Mental performance emotional
health you name it I've been drinking
fermented poo air tea specifically
pretty much every day for years now puer
tea delivers more polyphenols and
probiotics than you can shake a stick at
it's like providing the optimal
fertilizer to your microbiome the
problem with goodpure is that it's hard
to Source it's hard to find real poo
error that hasn't been exposed to
pesticides and other nasties which is
super common that's why Peaks fermented
puer tea crystals have become my daily
go-to it's so simple they have so many
benefits that I'm going to get into and
I first learned about them through my
friends Dr Peter attia and Kevin Rose
Peak crystals are cold extracted using
only wild harvested leaves from 250 year
old tea trees I often kick start my
mornings with their pure green tea their
poor black T and I alternate between the
two the rich earthy flavor of the black
specifically is amazing it's very very
it's like a a delicious Barnyard very
peaty if you like whiskey and stuff like
that they triple toxin screen all of
their products for heavy metals
pesticides and toxic molds contaminants
commonly found in tea there's also zero
prep or Brewing required as the crystals
dissolve in seconds so you can just drop
it into your hot tea or I also make iced
tea and that saves a ton of time and
hassle their fermented teas have never
been discounted but for you my dear
listeners only for you and for a limited
time Peak is offering up to 20 off plus
a free sampler pack with six of their
best selling teas when you order their
Puerto teas this all comes with a 30 day
satisfaction guarantee so it's risk-free
check it out go to peaklife.com Tim
that's
p-i-q-u-e-l-i-f-e.com forward slash
t-i-m peaklife.com Tim and the discount
is automatically applied at checkout out
enjoy
this episode is brought to you by
Shopify Shopify is one of my favorite
companies out there one of my favorite
platforms ever and let's get into it
Shopify is a platform as I mentioned
designed for anyone to sell anything
anywhere giving entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so what does that mean that means in no
time flat you can have a great looking
online store that brings your ideas
products and so on to life and you can
have the tools to manage your day-to-day
business and drive sales this is all
possible without any coding or design
experience whatsoever Shopify instantly
lets you accept all major payment
methods Shopify has thousands of
Integrations and third-party apps from
on-demand printing to accounting to
Advanced chat Bots anything you can
imagine they probably have a way to Plug
and Play and make it happen Shopify is
what I wish I had had when I was
venturing into e-commerce way back in
the early 2000s what they've done is
pretty remarkable I first met the
founder Toby in 2008 when I became an
advisor and it's been in spectacular
I've loved watching Shopify go from
roughly 10 to 15 employees at the time
to 7 000 plus today serving customers in
175 countries with total sales on the
platform exceeding 400 billion dollars
what does that really mean that means
every 28 seconds more or less a small
business owner makes their first sale on
Shopify more people in more places of
all ages every single day they power
millions of entrepreneurs from their
first sale all the way to full scale and
you would recognize a lot of large
companies that also use them who started
small so get started by building and
customizing your online store again with
no coding or design experience required
access powerful tools to help you find
customers Drive sales and manage your
day-to-day gain knowledge and confidence
with extensive resources to help you
succeed and I've actually been involved
with some of that way back in the day
which was awesome the build a business
competition and other things plus with
24 7 Port you're never alone and let's
face it being an entrepreneur can be
lonely but you have support you have
resources you don't need to feel alone
in this case more than a store Shopify
grows with you and they never stop
innovating providing more and more tools
to make your business better and your
life easier go to shopify.com Tim that's
s-h-o-p-i-f-y.com Tim all lowercase for
a free trial and get full access to
shopify's entire Suite of features start
selling on Shopify today go to
shopify.com Tim right now and check it
out they have a lot to offer shopify.com
Tim optimal minimals at this altitude I
can run flat out for a half mile before
my hands starts shaking so now I answer
your personal questions
[Music]
foreign
girls ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show where it is usually
my job to deconstruct world-class
performers to tease out their routines
habits Etc that you can apply to your
own life and lives this episode is
something different it's an experimental
format that I am super excited about and
apparently so are many of you it's
backed by popular demand this is an
episode that scratches an itch I've had
for many years now I'm not always able
to listen to every great podcast episode
out there even when they are by some of
my closest friends to answer that
predicament I decided to ask them many
of my friends to send a top segment from
their own podcast
podcasts that I could listen to and more
importantly also share with you my dear
listeners my team edited them together
and here we are this episode is a
compilation of roughly 15 to 30 minute
clips from some of the best podcasters
and also best interviewees in the world
and certainly some of my favorites at
the beginning of each clip you will hear
an intro from the host and where to find
their work and podcast at the end I'll
also share one or two of my favorite
clips from episodes of the Tim Ferriss
show you can view this episode as a
buffet and I strongly suggest that you
check out the shows included if you like
my podcast you will very likely enjoy
the featured shows in this episode for
the full list of the guests featured
today see the episode's description or
as usual head to tim.blog podcast for
all the details and before you go
do you like this format please let me
know on Twitter at T Ferris
t-f-e-r-r-i-s-s and also mention CC at
Team Tim Ferriss if you remember without
further Ado please enjoy
foreign
[Music]
my name is Matt Walker and I am a
professor of neuroscience at the
University of California Berkeley I'm
also the author of the book why we sleep
and I've given a couple of TED Talks
here and there as well I'm also the host
of the Matt Walker podcast a sample of
which I wanted to offer here
now I think it's safe to say that when
most podcasters think about Their
audience perhaps uh falling asleep or
nodding off while listening it can be
profoundly disheartening
however based on the topic of this
podcast I'm going to actively encourage
that kind of behavior from you
um in fact knowing what I know
particularly about the relationship
between sleep and memory it's the
greatest form of flattery for me to
think that people like you cannot resist
the urge to strengthen and consolidate
what I'm telling you by falling asleep
so
um please just feel free to ebb and flow
in and out of Consciousness throughout
the entire episode I'll take absolutely
no offense and today in terms of the
episode we're going to speak about two
things first I'm going to tell you about
the impact of alcohol on your sleep
which right from the off is going to
make me uh deeply unpopular
um and if that wasn't bad enough I'm
going to follow it up by speaking about
the impact of caffeine on your sleep so
let's first speak about nightcaps and
here by the way I'm not speaking about
the physical kind what I'm talking about
here is the liquid kind we're talking
about alcohol and sleep so we're going
to talk a little bit about what alcohol
is as a chemical then we'll speak about
how alcohol impacts your sleep and then
we'll explain why it is that alcohol has
these harmful impacts on your sleep
alcohol is perhaps one of the most
misunderstood sleep aids that there is
out there as we're going to learn it is
anything but a sleep aid and even though
people may feel as though a wee drink in
the evening or several drinks in the
evening may be helping their sleep in
fact it's harming your sleep alcohol
will impact your sleep in three specific
ways first alcohol is in a class of
drugs that we call the sedatives and
sedation is not sleep but when we've had
a drink in the evening we mistake the
former for the latter we mistake
sedation for sleep and I should probably
explain in a little more detail what the
differences between those two because
sedatives such as alcohol will
effectively switch off brain cell firing
particularly in your cortex
sleep on the other hand is very
different
as we learned about in the first episode
of this podcast it's during sleep and
especially during deep sleep when
hundreds of thousands of brain cells all
of a sudden decide to sing together in
this amazing feat of coordination and
they all fire together and then they all
go silent together and then they fire
together and then they all go silent
together and that's very different to
sedation and if I were to show you the
electrical signature of your sleep when
you have alcohol on board versus a
natural night of sleep you would
recognize that those two electrical
signature patterns are very different so
that's the first issue regarding alcohol
we shouldn't mistake sedation for sleep
but when we've had a few drinks in the
evening we tend to think that we fall
asleep more quickly in reality or were
actually doing is losing Consciousness
more quickly we're not going into
naturalistic sleep the second issue with
alcohol is that it fragments your sleep
in other words alcohol will litter your
sleep with many more Awakenings
throughout the night one of the problems
by the way with these short Awakenings
is that you typically don't remember
them but it still leaves your sleep
peppered or littered with all of these
brief Awakenings in other words your
sleep is less continuous
and a good example of this is a recent
experimental study conducted in a sleep
laboratory if you take a group of
healthy adults and you give them a body
standardized dose of alcohol one that
would probably just put you right at the
legal blood alcohol content limit for
driving and then you let the Sleep
recordings offer the sort of the jewelry
verdict as it were relative to a placebo
night of sobriety sleep especially in
the second half of the night was far
more fragmented when alcohol had been
taken on board indeed come the last four
hours of the night those participants
spent 94 more time awake having had
alcohol in the evening relative to when
they were sober because of that
fragmentation of your sleep caused by
alcohol despite the fact that you don't
remember it you wake up up the next
morning and you don't feel restored by
your sleep you don't feel refreshed by
your sleep the third concern with
alcohol is that it will block your rapid
eye movement sleep or what we often
think of as dream sleep in fact alcohol
is one of the most potent suppressors of
REM sleep that's perhaps concerning
considering that REM sleep is associated
with a constellation of different
benefits both for your brain and also
for your body and will speak about those
in subsequent episodes but this includes
things such as learning and memory
creativity rebalancing your moods and
your emotions and downstairs in the body
REM sleep is associated with the
recalibration of numerous different
hormone systems including for example
testosterone and more recently we've
discovered that REM sleep is
significantly associated with your
longevity and the less REM sleep that
you have predicts a shorter lifespan so
in other words REM sleep seems to be
critical for numerous aspects of Health
and Wellness even for the fundamentals
of life
which brings me on to one of the strange
side effects of alcohol
some people
um
and I'm not suggesting it's you
listening to this but let's just say
some hypothetical people may have gone
out on a Friday night or a Saturday
night and they've had a good number of
drinks and the next morning they may end
up experiencing very Vivid very strong
and very intense dreams why is this well
it turns out that your brain keeps a
clock counter of how much REM sleep you
should normally have and how much REM
sleep that you have lost as a
consequence of alcohol being in your
system
the brain throughout the night then
starts to build this incredible hunger
for REM sleep this drive for REM sleep
because it's been starved during the
early part and the middle part of the
night as the alcohol has been washing
around in your system and then if you
sleep late into that subsequent morning
into a Saturday or a Sunday morning
after a few too many drinks your brain
will try to get back some of the REM
sleep that it has lost so then as you're
sleeping late into that subsequent
morning after a night of a few too many
drinks your brain is clever having kept
a clock counter of how much REM sleep
you should have had but how much REM
sleep you have not been able to achieve
it will try to get back some of the REM
sleep that has been absent this is what
we call a REM sleep rebound effect in
other words the brain in those last few
hours of the night when your liver and
your kidneys have finally cleared out
the alcohol we'll not only try to get
the normal amount of REM sleep that you
would have but it will also try to get
back some of the REM sleep that you have
lost as a consequence that's why you
have these really intense really Vivid
dream experiences and again just to make
mention the brain never gets back all of
the REM sleep that it's lost it will
only get back some of that REM sleep
during the REM sleep rebound effect
so that's a little bit about what
alcohol is and the three different ways
in which alcohol can disrupt your sleep
and also some of the ways that it can
give you some rather strange rather
vivid dreams on the morning after so
that's sleep and alcohol but now let me
transition to something different sleep
and caffeine this is perhaps going to
sound strange coming from someone like
me but I'm going to suggest that you
drink coffee
because the health benefits associated
with coffee are numerous and many of
them are significant and in a separate
episode of my podcast that we won't
feature here I will tell you why coffee
is associated with those health benefits
but for the rest of this episode we're
going to focus on exactly what caffeine
is as a substance and then we'll dive
deep into how caffeine can impact your
sleep at night in several different ways
also we'll speak about how and why
different people can be more or less
vulnerable to the effects of caffeine so
let's start with exactly how caffeine
Works in our previous episode on sleep
pressure we learned all about how
caffeine can keep you awake during the
day here we're going to focus on how
caffeine can impact your sleep at night
caffeine is in a class of drugs that we
call the psychoactive stimulants and I'm
sure that you knew that caffeine was
some form of a stimulant however there
are several hidden consequences of
caffeine that you may be less aware of
one of these is the duration of action
caffeine has what we call a half-life of
about five to six hours in the average
adult in other words after five to six
hours fifty percent of that caffeine is
still going to be in your system what
that means is that caffeine will then
have a quarter life of about 10 to 12
hours
so in other words let's say that you
have a cup of coffee at 2 p.m in the
afternoon
almost a quarter of that caffeine could
still be circulating in your brain at
midnight or perhaps even more than a
quarter of that caffeine and the
probably rather crass analogy here would
be that if you have a cup of coffee at
2PM it would be the equivalent of
getting into bed at midnight and just
before you turn the lights out you Swig
a quarter of a cup of coffee and you
hope for a good night of sleep and it
tends not to happen in part this comes
back to the stimulant properties of
caffeine
first caffeine is going to make it more
difficult for you to fall asleep when
your head hits the pillow added to this
is the fact that caffeine will increase
levels of anxiety so as you're lying
there not being able to fall asleep you
suffer that sort of terrible experience
of a a racing mind that won't shut off I
almost liken this to a sort of a Rolodex
of anxiety that can flood your brain due
to the effects of caffeine
the second and related issue is that not
only will caffeine make it harder for
you to fall asleep it will then also
make it more difficult for you to stay
asleep soundly across the night this is
because caffeine will make your sleep
more unstable in other words it will
cause you to wake up more frequently at
night
and the consequence is something that we
call Sleep fragmentation meaning that
your overall sleep efficiency or the
quality of your sleep becomes
significantly worse when you have
caffeine on board
as a quick aside some people will tell
me look I am one of those individuals
and I can have an espresso with dinner
and I fall asleep and I stay asleep so
no harm no foul well yes and no even if
you fall asleep easily and then you stay
asleep across the night caffeine will
still decrease the amount of deep sleep
that your brain can generate and I'll go
into that in far greater detail in the
second episode but I make that point
because most people are not consciously
aware of the lack of that deep sleep
even though they don't remember having a
hard time falling asleep or staying
asleep and in fact why don't I just
pause for a second let's Linger on this
common statement that I receive from
people about their sensitivity what we
know is that the effects of caffeine are
highly variable from one individual to
the next I said earlier that the quarter
life of caffeine is somewhere between 10
to 12 hours but that's for the average
adult it's really quite different from
one person to the next that you will
pass on the street using a variety of
different assessment techniques and
methods what we've recently discovered
is that your sensitivity to caffeine is
due in part to your genetics
different people will have a more or
less efficient version of an enzyme that
breaks down caffeine and if you're if
you're nerd curious like me the class of
liver compounds that we're talking about
here are called cytochrome
p450 enzymes
I've always thought by the way that
cytochrome p450s would be a great title
for an album don't you think that would
be brilliant
um no probably just me anyway getting
back to the story some people will have
a version of that enzyme that allows
them to metabolize the caffeine very
quickly whereas other people will have a
version of that enzyme or set of enzymes
it turns out which is much slower in its
speed of breakdown of that caffeine and
as a result that caffeine will linger in
their system far longer than it would do
in someone who can metabolize it quite
quickly
for those people who can't metabolize it
and cleanse the system of the caffeine
as quickly those are the people who are
highly sensitive to the effects of
caffeine by the way unfortunately having
run my own genetic screening test I am
one of those slow caffeine metabolizers
ah it makes me so sad because I adore
the smell of freshly ground coffee I
love that ritual I would say however
that decaffeinated coffee if you find
the right one can be almost as
extraordinary but again I'm telling my
story this is not about me this is about
you and this podcast if you would like
to know by the way which caffeine
sensitive type you are there are several
genetic testing kits out there and I
won't name names that you can easily buy
online and they will often assess those
specific set of relative genes and once
again if you're curious the two most
relevant genes for you to look at out
for regarding this caffeine sensitivity
are called
cyp1 A2 and a h r
um
total alphabet spaghetti wasn't it and
with that spaghetti thrown against the
informational wall of today's episode I
will simply say thank you for listening
and if you want to connect with me
further you can find me on Twitter using
the handle at sleep Diplomat you can
find me on the web at sleep
diplomat.com but mostly and if you've
not lost the will to live listening to
my Dulce British tones at this point you
can listen to many more episodes from
this which is my podcast it's called the
Matt Walker podcast on all of your
standard podcast platform
so take care and goodbye from me
[Music]
hey everyone it's Adam Grant welcome
back to rethinking my podcast on the
science of what makes us tick I'm an
organizational psychologist and I'm
taking you inside the minds of
Fascinating People to explore how they
think and what we should all rethink
today's guest is atua gawande a surgeon
Harvard Professor New Yorker writer and
best-selling author of books like
complications and being mortal
I've long admired a Tool's work on error
checklists and coaching and in a
conference last year I got to see his
confidence and compassion first hand
when he helped rescue me from a severe
allergic reaction thanks the tool in
January 2022 he started a new job in the
white house as assistant administrator
of usaid's Bureau for Global health so
it's a perfect time to talk with him
about Leadership Learning from mistakes
and how he works with his coach
you chose surgery that's an enormously
consuming career somehow if you manage
to find time to write for the New Yorker
how did your identity expand from I'm
just going to be a surgeon and that
could that could take up all my time to
I'm actually going to have a side gig as
a prominent writer the best advice I got
which came late in life but seemed to
register was a colleague who said just
say yes until you're 40. and after 40
just say no when you're young you don't
know
what actually energizes you and what you
will prove to be good at you don't have
a sample size to know and I started with
a base assumption that I grew up around
medicine so I could be comfortable in it
but even in medicine you don't know what
you're going to be when you grow up what
kind of field do you want to go into do
you want to lead people do you want to
go deep in a technical area do you want
to be in a research lab do you want to
do startups do you want to do Public
Health there's so many different
directions to go and I just said yes I
hit college and found my mind was blown
I was from a rural town in Ohio and
there was incredible possibilities I
ended up going to a place like Stanford
where everything was open to me it was
too much choice and so I just started
saying yes to stuff and then I paid
attention to the things that actually
energized me just finding time flew when
I did certain things I was very into
Stephen J Gould the writer on Evolution
I was very in to health policy and I was
very into understanding clinical trials
and how you create impact in science
that blossomed into saying yes to
spending time on presidential campaigns
around health care and I worked for Gary
Hart and Al Gore when he ran long story
short by the time I got out of college I
was ready to do several things that took
10 years to fit together I did a degree
in politics and philosophy I worked on
the hill in Washington
I started my training in surgery
I would end up getting a degree in
public health during my surgery training
and when I put it all together the thing
that was totally unexpected was I had
stuff to write about and I began writing
for slate magazine and that became the
New Yorker magazine I loved surgery
and I found I could have technical
skills in how to build Public Health
interventions and make it work
and only later
that I reached that point
my late 30s hitting 40 where I said no
to everything except how I could put
together writing as a way of exploring
what I was experiencing in day-to-day
medicine and the failures of the system
and how we cope with the fact that we
now are in a world where
we can live into our 80s on average if
we can access the capabilities of a
science that has given us drugs medical
and surgical procedures Public Health
interventions
but only part of our population gets to
have that advantage in the United States
or around the world and our job has
become to deploy that capability town by
town to everybody alive and I get to
explore it through writing I get to live
it through my practical work as a
surgeon I did and then I built a Public
Health institution around starting to
solve problems in making that work and I
found my life's purpose doing that it's
amazing I'm so fascinated by this advice
you got to say yes until you're 40.
which on the one hand I I think you make
a very compelling argument that it's a
great way to discover what your passions
are or develop those passions and also
hone your skills it also sounds like a
recipe for indentured servitude and
possibly burnout
you also have to attention to what is
exhausting you and you got to pair that
out because that's the cause of burnout
right you are finding your own balance I
found for me my personality I was doing
surgery and that energized me even
though I was in the middle of surgery
residency even though at that time was
110 hours a week
I still was fired up about it I hated
staying up all night I couldn't stand
that I saw the light at the end of the
tunnel that that might end
but then I'd weirdly I'd get home and a
friend said would you write for slate on
Health Care stuff and I found I was
making time at nine o'clock at night
to work for a couple of hours and
I was doing it like that was a signal to
me I was not energized spending time in
Labs so
I just stopped the stuff that I didn't
have the energy to do there was a lot of
things that I quit a lot of things that
I quit so that I wasn't burning out and
even today the work can be overwhelming
at times but I'm marshalling my energy
around spending as much of it doing the
things that I can value and enjoy
there's always crap there's always a
grind in everything and that part is
there it's just there has to be some
Saving Grace that keeps you going what's
the worst advice you've ever gotten well
the constant advice I got early on which
is you have to pick one thing a tool
[Music]
and I just resisted it because some
people will be brilliant and best diving
deep into one thing
but there's lots of creativity at the
edges of combining Fields combining
approaches and so I combined surgery and
public health and then I combined in
writing in that work and
that is where I'm successful it may not
be the same way other people are until
one of my other favorite pieces of
writing of yours was the article you
wrote on on having a coach
and I remember seeing this headline and
thinking of course it makes perfect
sense athletes have coaches musicians
have coaches everyone else should too if
they want to be at the top of their game
you have a coach yes so you're eating
your own dog food or drinking your own
champagne depending on
how that's going what's that been like
what are you learning I think it's one
thing to to be coached in a profession
like surgery right which is very task
oriented to be coached as a leader is
much broader much more ambiguous in many
ways I'd love to hear what that's been
like and what you've learned about
coaching through this experience you
know that piece was prompted by
recognizing that I was paying like 125
bucks
to have a tennis coach
and that Roger Federer Rafael Nadal
Djokovic the top players in the world
all have coaches
but that is not our Paradigm in whole
swaths of other professions we have a an
educational Paradigm you will put in
your 10 000 hours of Education
and then you will be a self-learner part
of the education is how to train and
Advance yourself and so which one was
correct music was really interesting to
me because in parts of music like voice
I got to speak to Renee Fleming the
opera singer all singers have coaches
they follow the sports Paradigm but in
things like violin
they don't have coaches and I got to
call up itsak Perlman the greatest
violinist of his generation and ask him
do you think you need to coach and he
said we don't have coaches and playing
violin but I always did
his wife that he met when he was at
Juilliard after a period of time as a
professional musician herself she
stopped playing to become his coach sit
in the audience observe
his performances
give him feedback and do it in effective
enough ways that he could improve set
new goals and move onward and that's
what I learned is the pattern of
coaching
effective coaching is different from
teaching
in that it involves an external view of
your own reality
and then ideally it orients around the
goals that you set for where you want to
advance it can give you a framework for
where you want to advance and so I tried
it out and I'm so glad you asked me
about this because I decided to bring a
coach into my operating room and it was
a fellow surgeon who was one of my
professors and one of the surgeons I
most wanted to be like named Bob Osteen
and he died just a couple weeks ago
cancer surgeon I just tremendously
admire and was my coach in the operating
room and would observe and we would set
goals I'm going to work on how my team
worked in these next few months I'm
going to work on my technical
skills I'm going to work on you know the
things we worked on most in the until I
stopped doing surgery in December which
was painful teaching and how I could be
a more effective teacher Translating
that into this atmosphere
as I started building Public Health
institutions I had a executive coach
that I engaged a guy named Alan Foster
he's terrific and we've been together
now for a decade and working on as I've
started up multiple organizations as
I've Advanced them along the way and now
in this role
and I actually think a lot of people
have executive coaches and it has become
a familiar thing but the key to it has
been not just my giving him my
independent view of the world but having
him do a 360. and we actually just came
through our 360 here with our team where
he reviewed and talked to all of my
leaders and we got inputs from more than
30 people including people reporting up
to me people above me people that we
have to work with as peers across the
government and you know identified
things that were going
well and the strengths I was building on
and the opposite things in that variably
it was the flip side of my strengths so
for example I'm I'm very energetic as
you might hear and and I'm also good at
making decisions and making them quickly
but I'm moving so fast that I'm not
communicating them and I'm not
recognizing how to move them down into
the organization and across to other
people I'm already moving on to my next
thing it's the Rubber Band Theory of
leadership you want the rubber band to
pull ahead enough that people are coming
with you not not fall so far behind they
people are just swinging around behind
you I will tend to go so far that I can
break the rubber band do you have
strategies for making sure that you take
that feedback seriously as opposed to
brushing it off and saying well that's
just how I work you better get with the
program
the main strategy is identify actions to
take which include
informing people here is what I've heard
and trying to set that model that you
make feedback part of the culture of the
place that you are advancing one line of
feedback one of many lines of feedback
was that I tended to interrupt people as
they were talking and that was really
bad and so we came up with that I would
owe ten dollars to the candy jar that we
kept out for people come walking through
and every time I interrupted people and
so people could call me out have
permissions ten dollars in the candy jar
and my whole goal was to get rid of the
candy jar like I wanted an empty candy
jar I I definitely never had an empty
candy jar and so it wasn't quite
accepting it it was recognizing that you
know it was trying to defuse it trying
to reduce it I reduced it but not
eliminated it and there's a certain
degree of you want to share the strength
so you're not sacrificing the strengths
along the way they're typically related
the strengths and the weaknesses
I think of Deborah tannen's work on what
she calls High consideration versus high
involvement conversation Styles and for
you to say listen when I interrupt that
doesn't mean I'm intending to be rude or
impolite it means I'm really engaged and
it's a sign that I'm excited to jump in
and build but as a leader I know that
carries a lot of weight and it might
silence people in the room it seems like
even being able to have that
conversation right is a helpful step
whether or not you make it to the candy
jar yes you know it's acceptable once in
a while but it can't be an acceptable
pattern the culture of a organization is
the worst behavior you tolerate we'd be
in a wonderful place if the worst thing
that happened is that the boss sometimes
interrupts you we have bigger problems
to work on in every organization I've
been part of because it's not just about
me it's also getting the organizational
feedback this I got out of in surgery
right you cannot have a functional
surgical world where you are not
recognizing there are behaviors that can
cost people's lives and then address
them and we have an institution every
Wednesday morning reviewing our deaths
and major complications for the patterns
that underlay them and when you're doing
that on a regular basis it's recognizing
failure occurs regularly and then you're
activating that we're going to look out
for them and then address what are the
worst things that happen and then our
plan for not tolerating them and uh and
I think that's absolutely crucial role
in public health work because of exactly
the reasons you mentioned the scale at
which we do this work we will have
failures we have risks we absolutely
have to take
and we have to drum out the worst
behaviors that set us behind and
identify where we can attack them
music to my ears well thank you Attila
this has been just packed with insight
and I'm so grateful for the work that
you're doing for not only the us but for
public health at scale around the world
well I'm always delighted to talk to you
Adam over the many years we've known
each other fantastic to get to do it in
the medium of your podcast which I'm an
avid listener to well thank you I'm glad
we didn't end up in the ER this time
cheers cheers we'll leave that story
first to be told later
seriously
thank you Arturo
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens I get asked all the time
what I would take if I could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
ag1 by athletic greens if you're
traveling if you're just busy if you're
not sure if your meals are where they
should be it covers your bases with
approximately 75 vitamins minerals and
Whole Food Source ingredients you'll be
hard-pressed to find a more nutrient
dense formula on the market it has a
multivitamin multi-mineral greens
complex probiotics and prebiotics for
gut health and Immunity formula
digestive enzymes and adaptogens you get
the idea right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin D supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin D I found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin D supplement to your daily
routine is a great great option for
additional immune support support your
immunity gut health and energy by
visiting athletic greens.com Tim you'll
receive up to a year's supply of vitamin
D and five free travel packs with your
subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com Tim
and now a clip from the Tim Ferriss show
my guest today I'm very excited about
Diana Chapman
c-h-a-p-m-a-n Diana is a co-founder of
the conscious leadership group and a
co-author of the book The 15 commitments
of conscious leadership which I am
rereading right now it just so happens
her passion is to help organizational
leaders and their teams eliminate drama
in the workplace and Beyond
I learned about this thing called the
drama triangle which many people out
there may have heard about but I
realized my whole life is running around
on this drama triangle and the drama
triangle was created by Stephen Cartman
back in the 70s and he defined ways in
which human beings get caught in
victimhood that create reactivity and I
realized I'm on the triangle most of the
time and there is a big cost to me and
my people when I'm on the drama triangle
and so that was the wake-up call for me
and then I just spent every day sense
looking for all the tools I can for how
to keep myself out of that triangle as
much as possible since you mentioned it
let's just jump right into
the drama triangle could you give us an
overview of what it is and how you might
use it
okay so Cartman says
many of us got trained to live in a
state of victimhood and there are three
unique flavors of victimhood in the
drama triangle we call them bases
so the first base is the pure victim and
the pure victim you know it's so hard
here I'm trying I don't know it's just
any kind of a oh help you know it's got
this very disempowered feeling and it's
somehow like they've got the power
somebody else has it not me and I'm very
at the effect of things so I could be at
the effect of my bank account at the
effect of this email that just came in
at the effect of the traffic at the
effect of the new policy on going back
to work at the effect of covid all those
things are forms of being a victim then
the next role in the drama triangle is
the villain and the villain's job is to
blame so I can blame me God I should
have known that or I should have been
more prepared or any should have over
here on me or I'm not smart enough or I
can't count on myself that's all billing
toward myself or we can villain toward
another you know you you're the reason
why I'm not having as much fun as I
could be having or we could be a villain
to a group of people which is very
popular in our culture so we all know
who's screwing it up for the rest of us
you know it's that group over there and
everybody's pointing to particular
groups who are the bad guys so villain's
very popular because it gets our
adrenaline really kicking I think it's
actually in the terms of service on
Twitter that you have to play that role
when you use the service anyway just a
side note please right right who's
screwing it up who's wrong yeah you
don't know you're wrong I'm right and so
the last role in the drama triangle is
the hero it's also called the reliever
or The Rescuer and the hero's job is to
seek temporary relief so
oh my God I had such a hard day today at
work let me call home I'm gonna drink my
alcohol or do my gaming or get lost in
Netflix or whatever I'm going to do to
give myself some temporary relief and it
works but I gotta do it again tomorrow
because tomorrow I'm going to come home
potentially burn out again and then I'm
gonna have to do the same pattern so
heroine is temporary relief over and
over again so I can hear on myself I
could hero another you know oh you look
like you're struggling at work and let
me take over some of your work that
you're doing I could do that from a
place of real presence but when I'm in
hero doing it I'm actually creating some
codependence where I keep needing you to
not be able to handle your work so I can
keep helping and then I'll resent you
over time and then we can hero them you
know there's lots of philanthropies
especially in the past they're getting
better at this now where we just throw a
bunch of money at a population and then
next year they have all the same issues
and they need more money and nothing
ever really changes so the key thing is
temporary relief so we all know the
story about you can give the man a fish
every night or you could teach him to
fish for himself so the hero gives the
man the fish night after night after
night and if you're off the drama
triangle you shift to a place where you
see people as empowered and the hero
asks good questions to help people get
more effective around them so my next
question I want to share an observation
from my rereading of the book and then
the next question just to plant the seed
is I'm going to ask you why it's called
the drama triangle what drama actually
means here but in my reread which I'm in
the middle of right now of the 15
commitments of conscious leadership
which was recommended to me by Dustin
and I think it was also recommended in
my last book and tribal mentors by
Dustin and
there's a section that I needed to
reread which was related to the drama
triangle and it pointed out that
the villain could take the form of
someone in a meeting who to try to
resolve conflict or maybe not resolve to
try to
minimize conflict always takes the blame
like eventually at the end of the
meeting they just say you know what it's
my fault I should have done this this
this this and this and it's easy at
least for me to conflate radical
responsibility
with overly blaming myself for
everything and I don't actually
have a great way to approach navigating
Discerning those two for me if that
makes any sense so we could try to
unpack that or we could jump to why it's
called the drama triangle but I'll let
you choose the direction well let me do
both so the reason why it's called the
drama triangle is because the whole
triangle is set up for it's I'm right
you're wrong you're to blame or I'm to
blame it's not asking everybody to
really take a hundred percent
responsibility for how they're
co-creating experiences so if I'm in the
drama triangle the villain if I'm taking
on I'm more responsible what happens is
I'll say oh I'm here at the meeting you
guys and look it's my fault I'll take
some of your responsibility and take it
all on me and so there is a place to say
hey I have a part in how I've co-created
this let me tell you my part that would
be me taking my hundred percent I would
also know that everybody else has a part
to play too
so I'm not taking on their
responsibility as well that's the
difference between a villain and
somebody who's just simply acknowledging
I have a role to play here goddess thank
you so we were chatting before we
started recording and you and I have
have spoken quite a few times before
we've met before I spent time together
and you asked me why I invited you on to
the podcast and there were a number of
answers I gave one of them was related
to
kinesthetic awareness or what our mutual
friend and your business partner Jim
Detmer
have called at least in my in his notes
to me for this conversation this may be
your turn for all I know BQ so like IQ
EQ but body intelligence
and I feel like you're very
well calibrated for this and when we
spoke maybe a year and a half ago two
years ago I was working on this notebook
you might recall and then as I kept
working on it and kept working on it I
kept coming up with great reasons to say
no to the entire book which was very
meta and I ended up stopping but we
spoke a lot about the whole body yes
and I would love to maybe use that as a
wedge to start the conversation because
I found this so incredibly helpful
when I am certainly prone to over
intellectualizing everything into some
extremely complicated Matrix or
spreadsheet or God knows what so could
you lead us into that in whatever way
makes sense
sure the idea is that we have these
different centers of intelligence so we
have our head our heart our gut and IQ
eqbq are some of the ways we might be
describing those things these days so
body intelligence is a recognition that
I have an instinctual awareness that is
known by my Sensations
known by how the body feels
and that there's a lot actually there
that if we start to drop into the body
and pay attention it's got a lot of
guidance for us as does our emotions as
does our intellect and so I do have a
ton of access to my body intelligence I
think it's what I lead with in my own
getting clarity about which directions
to go in my life
and I've put a lot of attention on it so
it's very palpable to me my body screams
often you know no don't do that even
though my intellect might have an
understanding of why let's if you
wouldn't mind walk people through how
they might understand and use the whole
body yes because for me
when something is screaming I'm decent
at paying attention but it's not always
a scream sometimes it's oftentimes it is
it is a little more nuanced so could you
walk people through the whole body yes
and what the flight checklist looks like
well I could have people if we wanted to
go through an experience of starting to
feel what their whole body yes and knows
feels like great yeah let's do that
let's do that can we do that it's very
experiential so it'll take about 10
minutes and I'll have people they're
listening I'd recommend they close their
eyes
we have all the time in the world this
isn't uh morning television okay so the
idea is that your body knows when
there's a no when there's a yes and when
there's a what I'm going to call a
subtle no
and we say anything other than a whole
body yes is a no and to your point it's
easy to hear those screaming no's but
not so easy to hear the subtle no for
example someone contacted our
organization the other day and he wanted
to talk and it wasn't clear to me
whether he was trying to sell us
something or whether he genuinely had
clients that he wanted to connect us
with and even in my I had suspicions
that it wasn't as clean as he was
suggesting and I asked for clarification
and his clarification still
I couldn't really tell
but my body did know I felt this flat
feeling in my body when I thought about
having the call and unfortunately my
head said well maybe you're not sure so
let's have the call and indeed it was a
sales call and it was not a good use of
my time and I quickly hung up that was a
time in which I skipped over my no
because it was very subtle and my
intellect started to get worried like
what if I'm missing something and you
know what if you don't know so I use
this all the time and I'm still learning
as I did just last week to pay attention
to the intelligences that are outside of
just my intellect and so for you all if
you want to learn more about this what
I'd like you to do is close your eyes
and I'd like you to bring to mind an
experience from the past that was deeply
valuable to you
it was something that was nurturing it
was something you would gratefully
repeat that scene again it could be a
time when you were celebrated it could
be a time when you were in a highly
creative state that made something
valuable it could be a time when you
were in nature feeling deeply centered
so I'd like you to go back into that
scene as best you can and
see the images of that scene
and hear the sounds
and as you're in that scene I want you
to start to pay attention to the body
and see if you can notice
just simply how the body is vibrating
right now
when you imagine yourself in that scene
seeing those images
hearing the sounds
how does your body vibrate
is there a particular direction in which
energy is flowing through the body
now some of you might go Diane I'm not
feeling anything here that's fine
just imagine if you were feeling
something
let it be okay that it might feel like
pretend just for now
is there a certain temperature
that you notice in the body
for some people they might feel very
specific Sensations it might feel like
shapes inside the body
and some people might be auditory and
hear tones
or see visuals in their Mind's Eye
what you're doing here is getting a map
of what does a whole body yes feel like
I'm just strolling around inside of the
body feeling what you're feeling no
right or wrong answers here and
everybody's so unique we all have our
own different ways we feel it
for me my body gets warm
there's a uprising of energy it flows up
for me
there's a push in the flow for me but
yours will be what it is
and so then I'd like you to take one
last
like a memory take a memory shot of this
so you can remember what this feels like
and then I'd like you to shake it off
and let it go
and then I want you to think of a scene
in the past that you don't want to
repeat and I don't recommend finding
something traumatizing find something
that you really didn't feel like was a
good use of your time didn't serve you
you don't want to repeat it ever again
or you prefer not to
so if you can bring that image to mind
and again
see the visuals of that memory and hear
the sounds
and I want you to notice what happens
now in the body
is there a different
way the body's vibrating
how is the direction of energy flowing
or not flowing in this version
is there a difference in temperature
any other significant Sensations or
shapes you feel in the inner on the body
and again tones
in the ears or visuals in your mind's
eye may also be included
and you're getting a map for what no
this is a big no I don't want I don't
want this
I don't think this is going to serve me
just mapping the territory in the body
for what does this feel like
and take one last picture of that and
shake that one off
and then we've got one more to do and
this is the subtle no this is similar to
what I was just describing earlier of
taking a meeting
you know it didn't kill me to take the
meeting it didn't hurt
lasted 10 minutes and I got off the
phone but I don't it wasn't a yes it
wasn't an live experience for me
so this is called a subtle no so I want
you to think back everybody's got in the
last two to four weeks
something that's happened in which it
was a
it wasn't bad wasn't good eh
see if you can come back and see that
scene in your mind's eye
and hear those sounds
and you're gonna check and see what's a
subtle no feel like for you
how do you experience that scene what do
you notice in the body
how does it vibrate here
how does energy flow
or not flow is there a difference in
temperature
what parts the body light up Sensations
and tones or visuals as well
trying on here and again if you notice
don't notice much that's okay just
imagine if you did notice what would you
notice
and this is your map for what a subtle
no feels like
and you want to remember this feeling so
that the next time somebody says hey you
want to go out to lunch or could you
meet me to talk about ABC that you if
you feel this likely it's an invitation
for you to try no
and so you can shake that one off and
then we'll bring our attention back
to the ongoing conversation
hey everybody my name is Rich Roll I'm a
writer an ultra endurance athlete and
host of the ritual podcast which
delivers long-form conversations with
the intent of extracting Timeless wisdom
from a variety of exceptional humans
specializing across a wide spectrum of
disciplines with the specific goal that
you as the audience member glean
actionable wisdom powerful insights and
practical guidance you can then apply to
improve your physical mental emotional
and spiritual lives
the ritual podcast is available on every
major podcast player and as a high
production quality video on YouTube you
can follow me at richroll on Twitter and
Instagram and on YouTube at youtube.com
richroll and you can find links to all
of these platforms resources and more at
richroll.com
so many thanks to Tim himself and
absolutely Stellar example of someone
doing the kind of vitally important work
that I respect and admire for this
opportunity to share with all of you a
small example of my podcast
the excerpt that follows centers on
mindset and is excerpted from my first
interview with former Navy SEAL turned
endurance athlete and author David
Goggins which was recorded back in 2017
and is I believe David's very first
podcast interview ever
for those not familiar David just might
be the toughest Athlete on planet Earth
he has completed many of the world's
most grueling endurance challenges
including running
203.5 miles in 48 hours as well as
securing top finishes at dozens of the
world's most grueling foot races of 100
miles or more demonstrating time and
again an absolutely superhuman capacity
for resolve and a preacher natural
ability to inspire others along the way
but perhaps David's greatest
accomplishment is that throughout his
life he has faced and overcome a series
of seemingly insurmountable obstacles to
become the man he is today obstacles
like asthma sickle cell anemia
psychological and physical abuse obesity
academic struggles and even A congenital
heart defect that often left him
competing and winning on a mere fraction
of his actual physical capabilities
as a result David's insights on mindset
and mental toughness are all the more
profound and actionable
as a quick note in this clip you'll hear
us discuss a race called bad water which
is often described as the world's
toughest foot race it's a 135 mile
non-stop jaunt across Death Valley and
culminating up Mount Whitney during
which David ascended 14 000 feet of
total elevation gain and endured
temperatures often exceeding 120 degrees
Fahrenheit
so without further Ado this is me and
David Goggins
so many people tell me I would love to
run bad water one day why the [ __ ]
haven't you done it you told me that
five years ago I had an idea about water
I did it in four months I qualified in
four days and ran the Damn Race I wanted
to be a Navy SEAL had to lose 105 pounds
in 60 days to get in and do it I lost
the weight and became a damn seal I
wanted to be a ranger at 41 years old
people go what are you gonna do next I
don't know I've already done it because
the second I thought about it I
researched it I didn't ask questions I
achieved it we waste tons of time not
starting our journey for asking so many
[ __ ] questions on how to start the
journey get an idea start walking and
figure this [ __ ] out as you go Vision
Quest
but David you don't understand my life
exactly I got you know I were I had to
get up at five and I worked till nine
and I got three kids and I'm barely
making ends meet it's cool that you can
do that but like it's just not possible
what I love about that is people can
come at me with all that crap all day
long when I say that right there to you
I was a full-time Navy SEAL there's 24
hours in a day I would do an ultra races
and how I did it was I had to be at work
at seven o'clock in the morning I woke
up at three o'clock in the morning
I ran and then I rode my bike to work
and I did the same thing and I came home
if you want it you will find time in
your life to do it if you don't want it
you will continue to do exactly right
now give me excuses
you can make up every excuse on why you
can't do it and that's why I can't
connect with you that's why you hear the
passion come out of me and you want to
say it's anger no because I know it can
be done
and you're telling me all this [ __ ] on
why it can't be done and then what you
do is he's crazy he's an academy no you
don't want it bad enough
if you want it bad enough you will
figure out how to make this [ __ ] happen
are you willing to like entertain the
possibility that you do have some talent
in doing this or is it all like you're
chalking it all up to preparation of
mine well like I said if anybody's
familiar with sickle cell
it's a blood disease that pretty much is
called sudden death syndrome a lot of
African-Americans you have it they pass
out and die my VO2 max is horrible my
hematocrit and all this stuff is
horrible and also having the hole in
your heart that the size I had it took
away a lot of my other thing like you
have like you have like uh you're
operating with 25 of your capability and
that's what I'm trying to tell people
right and I was trying to tell people
everybody thinks that they want to
believe and I wish I was
after every race I was either in a
wheelchair or whatever because running
with sickle cell is is just not the
smartest thing to do those those
distances
at Mile 50 of every 100 mile race man I
was destroyed
and I just had to find but the feeling
of
the next 50 miles I had to go I learned
a lot about David Goggins and and the
will it was always me against me so no I
don't have any ability see this is the
heart of the whole thing though because
I think it's really important because if
you are a genetic freak of nature then
it's very easy for somebody to shrug you
off like oh yeah well he does it but
like he's Dave Goggins right I mean like
normal people can't do that and for you
to always anchor it and bring it back to
look man these are the challenges that
I'm facing I'm facing I have to overcome
more of these challenges than the
average guy like I'm actually starting
at a deficit like this and I'm not going
to ever let anybody make themselves feel
better
by telling me that I was some genetic
freak I'm not going to make yourself
feel better about that you I suffered
and I always say suffer because that's
what I did it was miserable the race is
every single race in hell week in buds
in Ranger school I suffered tremendously
I was not I should never have been able
to do it
which is why I'm so proud of myself I
don't care what place I came in I don't
care I walked 105 miles of bad water
I did it that was the journey that was
the mission that was about it's not
about oh well this guy's just a freak if
that makes you feel bad it's fine no you
can do it of just a breath of air in the
right mindset that's the message so you
you watered down my messes by putting me
in a category if I'm crazy I'm a freak
whatever all of those arguments are
comfortable arguments to allow people to
stay stuck in whatever situation exactly
you know what I mean right so it's more
uncomfortable if they have to actually
reckon and wrestle with the fact that
you are like them just like them and and
knowing what people don't want to do
that just like look in the mirror right
and right so tell me about the the
mirror thing is a big thing with you
right it's a huge thing for me it's
called the accountability mirror so I
talked about childhood and if anybody
thinks I'm some great person listen to
my childhood again
I had to change my thinking process and
basically the accountability mirrors
what did it I started shaving my head in
my face when I was 16 years old
and I realized when I started shaving my
face in my head you have a lot of time
to look at your reflection
and for some it sparked him I'm like man
I I'm a piece of crap I duck school I
Duck score I barely in graduating I'm
I'm this I'm this I'm this I'm all these
things man and I had to really
tell myself the truth and so many people
when you say you're dumb
the first thing he would say Oh no
you're not if you're dumb you're dumb
if you're fat you're fat but if you're
not willing to tell yourself that and
everybody around you in your circle
continues to give you this positive
feedback if you suck you suck
if you tell yourself you suck that is
when you become great well then you're
you're getting into the solution that is
what I'm talking about so that
accountability was I gotta get to the
surface of who I'm not
and I held myself accountable I lied to
this person today I'm a liar I'm a
cheater I'm this I'm that now I tell
myself
and I've fixed these issues and fixed
these issues and that part was hard it
was hard to not be jealous of this
person who had this and this and this
had nothing
nothing it was hard to tell this person
yeah I'm jealous of you
and I'm insecure I'm a very insecure guy
and I have nothing it was hard to look
at all I'm not real smart but I had to
fix these issues and the accountability
mirror was now look at myself in the
mirror and say wow you fix these issues
right so that's the thing that you
consciously practice every day every day
in my life in the mirror every day of my
life even now so if I were to say some
little white lie
and I go to the mirror in the morning
time I see my hands like man why the
hell did you say that to that guy
and he will get a call from me and say
look dude I I it's like that's like 12
step man it's like doing your daily
inventory and like making amends for
your [ __ ] that's it you know what I
mean because you're only lying to
yourself so when you see this you know
we're in this cultural malaise right now
where like every kid gets a
participation Trophy and like we have to
tell everyone that they're great yeah
you know what I mean it's all about like
feelings and everybody's a special
Snowflake and all of that like you know
that must make you insane it makes me
more than insane it's the destruction
of this country
and I love this chemistry I've I fought
hard for it I will continue to fight
forward and hopefully through
mental toughness it takes mental
toughness to change how you look at
things
and giving a person a trophy saying
you're great when you're really not if I
had that growing up there would be no
David Goggins zero there'd be no tough
people none which is why the world is
where it is today
some weak people right there's a lot of
weak people now right
so let's wrap it up with this if you can
like
distill
everything that you're about into like
kind of One Core message that you want
people to take away like what is it
beyond what we've already talked about
what is it that's holding people back
that's limiting them that's keeping them
stuck and in their blind spot and how
can you speak to that to perhaps Shake
It Loose a little bit and get people to
think a little bit differently about how
to proactively approach their lives
the truth
their truth the real truth about who
they are as a person I think it all
really starts there the truth and
knowing that you may not be a courageous
person you may not have this and that
but are you willing to
find it within yourself to go through
the very hard journey
a lot of people in this world have died
80 90 100 years old and they lived a
great life he had a lot of things
but a lot of people who have died never
really started the true Journey that
whatever you believe in God or whatever
you believe in if you believe in nothing
I believe we're all here to start a
journey and that journey is [ __ ] hard
if you choose your real journey most of
us
we decided to take a different journey
in life it's a journey of least
resistance
and so
what I challenge people to do
is to realize that in themselves that
yeah I have taken a lot of left turns
when I shouldn't stay straight because
why
I wasn't good at something
and it embarrassed me to not be good at
something or I wasn't the smartest
person of this or that whatever is all
these excuses are to be built up find
the truth of Who You Are
go back to the start of your journey
and go down that path I guarantee you if
you finish that Journey and you don't
fear and waver and and go places that
are very easy the other end of that
Journey let me tell you is a peaceful
end
hey guys this is Tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet Friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet Friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that I send out every Friday to
share the coolest things I've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles I'm reading books I'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that get sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcasts guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then I test them and then I share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about if
you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.com Vlog Friday type that into your
browser Tim dot blog slash Friday drop
in your email and you'll get the very
next one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by
Shopify Shopify is one of my favorite
companies out there one of my favorite
platforms ever and let's get into it
Shopify is a platform as I mentioned
designed for anyone to sell anything
anywhere giving entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so what does that mean that means in no
time flat you can have a great looking
online store that brings your ideas
products and so on to life and you can
have the tools to manage your day-to-day
business and drive sales this is all
possible without any coding or design
experience whatsoever Shopify instantly
lets you accept all major payment
methods Shopify has thousands of
Integrations and third-party apps from
on-demand printing to accounting to
Advanced chat Bots anything you can
imagine they probably have a way to Plug
and Play and make it happen Shopify is
what I wish I had had when I was
venturing into e-commerce way back in
the early 2000s what they've done is
pretty remarkable I first met the
founder Toby in 2008 when I became an
advisor and it's been and spectacular
I've loved watching Shopify go from
roughly 10 to 15 employees at the time
to 7 000 plus today serving customers in
175 countries with total sales on the
platform exceeding 400 billion dollars
what does that really mean that means
every 28 seconds more or less a small
business owner makes their first sale on
Shopify more people in more places of
all ages every single day they power
millions of entrepreneurs from their
first sale all the way to full scale and
you would recognize a lot of large
companies that also use them who started
small so get started by building and
customizing your online store again with
no coding or design experience required
access powerful tools to help you find
customers Drive sales and manage your
day-to-day gain knowledge and confidence
with extensive resources to help you
succeed and I've actually been involved
with some of that way back in the day
which was awesome the build a business
competition and other things plus the 24
7 support you're never alone and let's
face it being an entrepreneur can be
lonely but you have support you have
resources you don't need to feel alone
in this case more than a store Shopify
grows with you and they never stop
innovating providing more and more tools
to make your business better and your
life easier go to shopify.com Tim that's
s-h-o-p-i-f-y.com Tim all lowercase for
a free trial and get full access to
shopify's entire Suite of features start
selling on Shopify today go to
shopify.com Tim right now and check it
out they have a lot to offer shopify.com
Tim
this episode is brought to you by Peak
that's p-i-q-u-e I have had so much tea
in my life I've been to China I've lived
in China and Japan I've done tea tours I
drink a lot of tea and 10 years plus a
physical experimentation and tracking
has shown me many things
Chief among them that gut health is
critical to just about everything and
you'll see where tea is going to tie
into this it affects immune function
Weight Management Mental performance
emotional health you name it I've been
drinking fermented poo air tea
specifically pretty much every day for
years now who are tea delivers more
polyphenols and probiotics than you can
shake a stick at it's like providing the
optimal fertilizer into your microbiome
the problem with goodpure is that it's
hard to Source it's hard to find real
poo error that hasn't been exposed to
pesticides and other nasties which is
super common that's why Peaks fermented
puer tea crystals have become my daily
go-to it's so simple they have so many
benefits that I'm going to get into and
I first learned about them through my
friends Dr Peter attia and Kevin Rose
Peak crystals are cold extracted using
only wild harvested leaves from 250 year
old tea trees I often kick start my
mornings with their puer green tea their
poor black tea and I alternate between
the two the rich earthy flavor of the
black specifically is amazing it's very
very it's like a a delicious Barnyard
very peaty if you like whiskey and stuff
like that they triple toxin screen all
of their products for heavy metals
pesticides and toxic molds contaminants
commonly found in teeth there's also
zero prep or bring required as the
crystals dissolve in seconds so you can
just drop it into your hot tea or I also
make ice and that saves a ton of time
and hassle their fermented teas have
never been discounted but for you my
dear listeners only for you and for a
limited time Peak is offering up to 20
off plus a free sampler pack with six of
their best-selling teas when you order
their Pooh RTS this all comes with a
30-day satisfaction guarantee so it's
risk-free check it out go to
peaklife.com Tim that's
p-i-q-u-e-l-i-f-e.com forward slash Tim
peaklife.com Tim and the discount is
automatically applied at checkout enjoy
[Applause]
foreign